I don't know what he's doing but he's
making that that Mariah Carey thing is
pretty amazing I can't do that you like
that noise rendering you try it okay
they said you can make that noise he was
entering you of course I was
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah he kept saying I just not good
audio yeah we need we can't find good
audio but he's obviously great singer I
mean if everyone knows he's a good
singer he's a good singer who was an
opera singer you got to do the Comedy
Jam next time it comes in I can't sing I
would you don't have to be able to sing
you got a sink be able to sound a little
bit dude I can't do it at all I've seen
people go up and they just have they
just [ __ ] do an ac/dc song anybody
can sing ac/dc know anybody can yeah you
can I saw the guy who runs less I liked
him
almost anybody not everybody no no no
you can't do it rich you try take the
teeth out no cuz I'm off eight hours I
can spit the gum out but they come out
picks it up
of course he does he's a [ __ ] Savage
from Jersey good okay you come too long
if you throw it I hear it from one wait
with stop this is gonna be really one
two three
wait why I was awesome
that was awesome yeah thanks thank you
guys that was really cool
that's not like ac/dc it was really I
thought it was that me yeah me too but
somebody was playing the record area
young but see that's not you can't do
like we could also do it down what's
your favorite Neil Young song that you
can do after the gold rush please hear
it I love that song that's why my
favorite I'll give you a pull up the
words on your computer will get it right
on this monitor take me a second to come
you know to get in door bring it up here
I'll bring it up on that cuz he can't
reach
are you doing
what's our do you want I am here to go
after the gold rush do you want the song
war in our house this treat that's your
tone Oh God after the gold I could do
ranging what is that that's actually
Mateos sister who is Shh I mean what did
she do she's a bodybuilder Wow one of
the hottest girls how old is she I don't
know would he help us
no she's she's got married I didn't know
less wrinkly okay oh she got a lovely
figure
okay beautiful I need you to focus on
the song really yeah I need you to get
into the spirit of things
sing into the might to it yeah where's
the booze trailer music for it so you
can sing it do you want like what do you
think Richie we don't have an we don't
have the Kerri oh we don't think I got
it start it and then just you know
enrich can you take over okay good idea
just to get him into a beast I've sung
this on my podcast so I'm you know what
you're doing yeah yeah good all right
let's go
well I dreamed I saw the knight in armor
called change something about a queen
there were peasants she
and drummers drumming and the archer
split the tree there was a fanfare
blowing to the Sun that was floating on
the breeze look at mother nature on the
run in the nineteen seventies and that
was a great that was a good falsetto
voice good you know sure you carried it
and threw it off a [ __ ] ledge it's
beautiful
you know stand up yeah when I sing okay
okay Sinnott babe remaining just not
user now that's the different cameras
madness house that's not it I know yeah
we want Neil Young yeah I'm an actress
at it apart I bet you are crosby Stills
and Nash saw Neil Young yeah yeah hit
the wrong guy you named okay it's tough
it's tough to remember everything you
know there's a karaoke version on
YouTube what are you doing what are you
gettin my dad he wants to hold the mic
yeah you have to unwrap it and are the
cameras are they gonna pick him up if
he's standing lost sit down
standing know whatever you wanted but
with other camera is the camera on voice
by the way yes that one's okay
all right yeah why don't you wait you
stay this way you can be free we got a
baby we should capture if you can pull
it off here here let me help you at the
cable a little bit Oh relax have some
pride it's not touching me off come on
yeah it's not goin ready
[Music]
you place the flowers in the vase that
you bought today staring at the fire for
hours and hours while I listen to you
play your love songs all night long for
me come to me now and rest your head for
just five minutes everything is good
such precocious the windows are I don't
know this first okay
they weren't you and funny the red the
red out sunshine through oh yeah right
yeah house is a very very very fine
house we're to catch in the yard life
used to be so hard now everything is
easy because of you
[Music]
lalalalala good job that was great right
yeah that was hard you make a fool of
yourself
thank God right
that song for a long time because I've
always loved it yeah I can tell by the
way you stopped in the middle when I
don't know this part session you should
it was really really good speaking he's
like the red light the red lines are
like other words are turning red as
you're supposed to saying them and he's
ready on nine verses that's what a real
artist does that's right because it was
done through passion yeah nice reading
well you know anybody he could I don't
know this part it's literally right
literally my good my tune to it the same
the same tone you've been you what do
you think just changed all of a sudden
there's no catch
I'm great at catch T I'll do one more
can't see much one son father and son
karaoke version of that father and son
oh it's up there all right here just put
Peyton don't goof off oh yeah I don't
take serious
stand up stand up and tell what everyone
who's stand up or sit Robbie get the
camera you're at least film yeah this
will be good yusuf islam now so
introduced it properly
yeah it's change his name
[Music]
it's not time to make a change just
relax take it easy you're still young
that's your fault there's so much you
have to know find a girl settle down if
you want you can marry look at me I am
old but I'm happy I was once like you
are now and I know that it's not easy to
be calm when you found something going
on seriously man LAN time kufan off but
take your time think a lot I think of
everything you've got for you we'll
still be here tomorrow but your dreams
mean how can I try to explain when I do
he turns away again it's always been the
same
same old story from the moment I could
walk talk I was ordered to see now
there's a way and I know that I have to
go away my eyes are emotional good job
you didn't sound like I'm like a total
idiot
I did the two voices have you ever heard
that song he changes he does the father
then he does he does I was I was really
worried you were gonna make an absolute
ass of yourself not me not when it comes
to that right now when it comes to
something I'm so passionate that was
great
actually we got the reviews already
coming in if you want to go to line five
I don't want to listen to that Brinson
and Georgia
what's up Princeton Brinson hey Brinson
Brinson oh my god that was bad I want to
drive much off the road know why I chose
your family